I mean here's the thing okay here we go
legitimately LM laughing at people
saying this is primarily driven by
bundle spoiler alert it's not the
majority of all Ragnarok copies sold
have been Standalone but to your point
bundles definitely didn't hurt though
that's what he said I mean he said
majority so far we know the majority is
8 million and they sold a couple million
off of bundle it's like that it is what
it is I'm not saying that the bundles is
the sole reason it's so well
I'm saying it definitely added a little
not a little a little bit
and now here's the thing though but we
can't like he said really can't over
emphasize how insane the numbers are 11
million sold in less than three months
for a console exclusive
that's big bro that's big yeah I think
that's the first between two consoles
that's